[MUSIC PLAYING]
JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC:
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to our talk today.
My name is Jelena
Pjesivac-Grbovic.
I'm a staff software
engineer at Google
and one of the technical leads
on Cloud Dataflow product.
Today, we're going to look
at the data processing
tools and their performance
and how the cloud processing
tools, Dataproc and
Dataflow, achieve
the excellent and optimal
performance out of the box.
So data processing performance--
why do we care about it?
Well, it matters
because it affects
the latency of our result.
So to achieve our result,
we have to spend time
running the pipeline
and depending how
efficient it is,
it affects when our
result is available.
Depending on what
your application is,
the time it takes to
get to the solution
can be make it or break
it event for product.
Another reason why the
performance matters
is the costs.
Your applications run
on the real hardware.
Running on real
hardware costs money,
whether you use the cloud
or you use the on-premise.
So if it's inefficient, you're
literally wasting money.
So that's important thing.
And combining these
two, performance
can make data analysis
feasible or unfeasible.
If it's too slow,
we don't need it.
If it's too expensive,
we cannot afford it.
So performance is really
critical in making it possible
for us to do a data analysis.
So what are the factors
that affect the performance?
There are many of
them, and first set
of factors we are
going to look at
are related to your application,
essentially the things that
are sort of in your control.
First thing is data
shape and distribution.
Are your old data records
approximately the same size?
Or do they vary a lot, right?
If you think of someone
processing a social graph,
a node that contains
the social butterfly
will be orders of magnitudes
bigger than a node containing
an average person.
The other thing that's sort
similar but slightly different
is the per-record computation
cost distribution.
Do all records cost the same?
Like, does it take
same amount of CPU time
to process each of your
records, or again, there
is a big difference?
If you think of something
that's processing map tiles,
like the processing a
map tile on Antarctica
versus processing a map
tile in San Francisco
probably incurs different
computation costs.
And finally, within
application space,
the one factor is
implementation efficiency,
how well you were at
like, optimizing it,
how well you were using the
APIs that are given to you,
how is your memory management,
and things like that.
So to address the
application factors,
there is a traditional
performance tuning
and optimisation process.
We profile our data and we
profile the application.
Once we understand our
data and application,
we can perfectly split our
data, partition it for execution
and parallel, and we can
perfectly schedule those tasks.
Of course, this perfect,
take with a grain of salt.
That we can perfectly
schedule the task,
Java will execute and produce
a result, and we'll be happy.
If that was it, like,
we're done right?
We've computed
everything we needed.
But in reality,
this is not the end.
We run our data processing
pipelines regularly,
sometimes even continually.
So this process is a process
that has to be repeated.
And it sort of works, except
expertise is required.
The person who can do
the profiling and data
and application is not
easy to find, right?
And the thing is, if you
have one application,
sure you can maybe afford
someone who will be your expert
and make it run great.
But if you have hundreds,
you really can't scale it.
So what happens then is
people copy tuning parameters
from the one that was tuned.
And it keeps going,
and you copy it and you
hope that it's going to achieve
the same performance benefit.
It did for original pipeline.
But guess what?
It usually doesn't.
And especially over
time, it gets worse.
And you may not be
even aware of it.
So the other aspect of where the
traditional performance tuning
and optimization
sort of break down
is that it's not
always possible.
If you have a complex
pipeline with multiple stages,
you may not be able to reliably
profile intermediate stages,
because that data depends on
actually data that came in.
And if that changes,
the properties
of the intermediate data change.
So you really can't
always benefit from this.
And finally, even if we
did everything perfectly
and we had a full knowledge, we
are running on the real system,
on the machines that will have
some things going on them.
And they will not
all behave the same.
And that brings us to
the execution environment
as a factor of our
data performance.
So a big part of execution
environment factors
are workers.
Some workers will be fast,
some workers will be slow.
Why?
Who knows.
There are many reasons why
workers can be slow or faster.
For example, most
of the work now
days runs in a VM that
share the physical machine,
and depending on the
quality of isolation,
one can affect the other.
The other thing that is
important is the networking.
So network conditions
are even less--
you can even less
isolate the networks
in terms of the impact.
And you know, someone else
using the same network you do
will affect your performance.
And finally, this is
like resource contention.
And this can be on
any possible level.
It can be resource
contention in your code.
It can be resource contention
in a worker that you're running.
It can be resource
contention on a VM,
or it can be resource contention
on a service that you rely on.
Imagine you're reading a
service that can support
certain amount of QPS, right?
And then there is a big user
that comes and pretty much
uses up everything.
Your job-- all the jobs will
slow down because of that.
So the impact of uneven
worker performance
gets worse with scale.
Amdahl's law tells
us essentially that.
And the more parallelism
we have, the more serious
bottleneck the serial part of
our application have become.
So how do we deal with
execution environment?
Well, I mean, you can
remove slow machines.
That's one.
But that's not something you can
do on demand and automatically.
What people do is usually
avoidance techniques, so things
like a backup or worker resets.
So if your application
can detect that something
is going slow, that
a worker is slow,
it can choose to use
a different worker
or it can schedule the work
done on that worker to someone
else who is faster.
And that's almost
it from the dealing
with execution environment.
Another factor that's related
to the execution environment
factor in this is the
system complexity.
Your application uses an SDK.
And when it runs, that SDK
runs on some kind of a worker
harness, your thing
that makes your API
calls and puts them in a system.
And that runs in some
kind of a container that
runs on a virtual
machine that may
be running multiple containers.
And that runs on
a physical machine
that may be running
multiple virtual machines.
And if you're doing distributed
application, guess what?
There are multiple
physical machines,
and they are connected
by a network.
So anywhere in this stack,
something going wrong
or something being slow
affects everything above it.
Yet we are not done
with the factors
that affect the performance.
We have our dependencies.
And I mention them, but we will
call them out here explicitly.
So one set of dependencies is
related to the client libraries
you use.
If you use inefficient
implementation of something,
it will affect performance
of your application.
And often client
libraries we use
are like I/O libraries,
your connector to something,
convenience libraries, like
a parser or a formatter,
and then some domain
specific libraries,
maybe some kind of a
math library or something
that you may need to actually
compute what you need.
System libraries are similar.
Your VMs and all this comes
with some predefined images.
And they can have a good set of
libraries are not so good set
of libraries.
OK, so to summarize,
the factors that
affect application performance,
we've seen they can be static,
like a system libraries
or something, or dynamic,
like the things that happen
at the runtime, which
were our worker and execution
environment, for example.
The data processing tools need
to adapt to the application
and the environment.
And the underlying
system and dependencies
affect application performance.
So with this, we'll look at
the two specific Google Cloud
processing tools,
Dataflow and Dataproc,
and how they tackle
different aspects
of the different factors that
affect application performance.
So first we will look
at the Cloud Dataflow,
and how it deals
with the application
specific dependencies
and environment.
And then we look at
the Dataproc and how
it deals with the system
level improvements.
So let's switch the gear
and talk a little bit
about the Cloud Dataflow.
Cloud Dataflow is a fully
managed, no-ops data
processing.
It offers unified batch
streaming processing power
and it uses open
source programming
model using Apache Beam.
It can intelligently design
to scale to millions of QPS
if you're using it in
the streaming mode,
and also can run really
large batch jobs.
So how does the working
with Dataflow looks like?
You wake up and you write
your Apache Beam pipeline.
Then you take it and you submit
it to Cloud Dataflow service.
The Dataflow service,
and it's behind,
has a bunch of back
ends that provide
many different services, some
of which we'll talk about,
that are sitting there
waiting for your jobs
to come in schedule.
So the service
will schedule here
job on one of these back ends.
This back end will take
your Beam pipeline,
run it through a graph
optimizer, do some annotations,
some analysis on it,
and it will come up
with a initial
configuration for your job,
and will start resources
for you on which you
will execute that job.
So it will start
GCs, it will start
allocate the buckets
and everything else
that you may need for this job.
Your job will start to run.
You'll access your inputs.
They can be on GCP or they
can be external sources.
You'll read them,
you'll process,
process, process, produce
the output, and you're done.
So this is our workflow.
So what are the benefits of it?
Well, it's fully managed
and auto-configured.
You don't have to worry about
deploying your packages,
your JAR files,
preallocating VMs.
You just submit, essentially,
your job to the service
and it runs.
And all the resources
that your pipeline uses
are allocated on demand.
We also do automatic
optimized execution graph.
So we'll talk about
that in a minute.
We also mitigate the stragglers
dynamically, using something
we call dynamic
worker balancing.
And we can automatically
scale at runtime
to match the throughput
your application needs.
So if you look at these
four benefits, three of them
are trying to address
the factors that
affect the performance.
So Apache Beam looking at the
optimizations-- the pipeline
graph versus execution graph.
What Apache Beam gives your
is very intuitive programming
model that allows you to express
the complex computation simply.
That's great.
Except that's really
not the way you
should be running
this application.
So once we have
your pipeline, we
run through many of the
optimizations algorithms
to provide the optimal
execution graph
that we can run that will
produce the output that you
want.
So this also, like
in this process,
while we are optimizing,
we try to estimate
what is the initial
configuration for your job
that we think will run it well.
And now, let's look
at the dynamic factors
and look at the stragglers.
So what is the straggler?
In this framework, the
straggler is a task
that takes longer to complete
than the average completion
time across all the workers.
So here is a graph,
and I'll explain it.
So first, on our
x-axis, we have time.
On y-axis, we have workers.
This is a gun chart of the state
of the workers at the given
time.
So each of horizontal
lines represents
a worker, and the tasks
that were running on it
at the given time, like
if you did a vertical cut.
So you can see
that in this graph,
the worker finished
the chart, it
will start working on the
next one, finish the task,
start working on the
next time, and things
are going pretty smoothly.
There's not huge variability
between the end times.
The execution with the
stragglers looks different.
Like, some of the tasks
are taking much longer
than the others.
And they're affecting
our end time.
Do these things happen in the
production, in your real jobs?
Oh yeah, they do.
So this is a typical
MapReduce liked pipeline,
where you have a read
operation, you group it by key,
and you write it.
This is a job with 400 workers
running for about 20 minutes.
And if you look at what
those 400 workers worked on,
there are these huge gaps
where many workers sat idly,
while few other workers
were trying to finish.
And this is a big
resource waste.
So to address these
issues of stragglers,
we employ a technique called
dynamic work rebalancing.
So how does it work?
So looking again on our
graph with the straggler,
we can see our completion
time of this job or stage
will be once the
red chart finishes,
once the red task finishes.
So what can we do?
How can we address this?
So first step in this
is straggler detection.
You first have to
identify a problem
so we can solve it right?
So what Dataflow does, it's
on continually monitors
amount of remaining work.
So imagine we're on
this gray line that
shows our current time.
And at that time, we check
what's the remaining work.
This would be our completion
time if we didn't do anything.
So we'd run our
algorithm to estimate
how much work is remaining,
and we come up with this should
be our average completion time.
If everything was
perfectly parallelizable
and we were able to
utilize all eight workers,
this is when our
job would finish.
So then, once we have
this information,
a worker can say,
huh, I'm behind.
So what I can do is split.
I can return fraction of my
work so other can work on it,
and I can finish what
I have in a given time.
And now we rebalance the work,
and the situation looks better.
It's not perfect, but we did
save some amount of time,
and their new completion
time is there.
Clearly, there is
more work to do.
We should be able to paralyze
this further, so guess what?
We do.
So we repeat this
process over and over
during the execution of the
job, and your workers constantly
get filled with the work.
So what's the impact
on the real job?
This is again, the
same application
we saw, like the 400 workers
spending a lot of time
waiting on others.
And this is how this application
looked like once we enabled
this dynamic work rebalancing.
So we see they're five minutes
out of 20, it's a quarter,
but this is a five minutes
out of 400 workers,
like 33 hours of CPU time.
So it's another small saving.
Now we've seen how dynamic work
rebalancing reduces straggler
tail and keeps worker busy.
But it's not the
only thing we do.
Autoscaling allows us
to match the number
of workers to the throughput
your application needs.
So it scales the number
of workers automatically
to ensure the pipeline is
keeping up with the demand.
It applies to both
batch and streaming,
but my example on this
graph is streaming.
So imagine your application
is up and running.
It has some kind of
a QPS, and we run it
with certain number of machines,
in this case having 12,
and things are going fine.
As the QPS increases, as
you are getting more hits
on your service, we will
grow the number of workers
to maintain the lag
of processing low.
And once the QPS
rate comes down,
we decrease the
number of machines.
Because there is no need
for them to be there,
you can keep up with the traffic
just with much fewer machines.
So how does the autoscaling play
out in a bad job, for example?
So we start the job, we
do some initial analysis,
like I said, during
the optimization,
and we come up with
a, we should run
this with the three workers.
And things start running,
and things look OK.
But again, we are continually
estimating when we will finish.
And at some point, we
have enough information
to conclude that this is
going to take much longer.
We should really be
working with 100 workers.
So great, OK, bring
up 100 workers.
The beauty of GCP and
easily scale up, right?
However, the
problem in this case
is we don't have
100 pieces of work.
We initially split
it into like 6 or 9,
whatever, because we thought
we needed three workers.
And this is where the dynamic
worker balancing kicks in,
because now, you
have 100 workers
and you can generate
work for them
by using dynamic
work rebalancing.
And this is actually
pretty cool.
We call it autotuning, like many
people call autotuning things.
And you can scale up and
scale down as needed.
This is a job that started
with tens of workers
and then decided that
they needed 1,000.
And the blue lines are
showing, essentially,
when the dynamic work
rebalancing happened.
Like, these are
the points in time
when we decided to split the
work and distribute it further.
And you can really see
that its going in stages.
But the framework is
essentially learning
what your application is doing
in a sense, and adapting to it.
Cool, so why does
this matter to you?
Well, because it helps the
real applications run better,
I hope.
So we will look at a case study.
There is this
application that one
of our sister teams in
Cloud ML cares about a lot,
so we're monitoring what
that application is doing.
And it's a standard ML
preprocessing pipeline.
It's applicable to
pretty much any ETL.
You take a data in some
format and you convert it
into format you want.
So this particular
application takes the data
in tab separated value
format, and converts it
into tensor flow
record format and input
data or click-through
logs from Criteo I think.
It's a Public data set.
And the pipeline is
reasonably straightforward.
This is our pipeline
graph from Dataflow UI.
So we have a stage
that reads from text.
Then we decode it.
And then we have this meet stage
called analyze and transform.
And then we encode the
output and we write it,
and we make a small side
output with some metadata
there, just store some
information about the run.
This is a
preprocessing step that
can apply to many, many users.
And those users will
differ on input sizes
and the content of the files.
And they will also differ
on analysis parameters
they want to do.
Like, this analyze
and transfer step
is the meat of transformation.
And it has some
things, like what
is the threshold for
merging the things?
How big of, you know,
output files you want?
Things like that.
And users may want to configure
the application differently.
These are not tuning parameters.
These are application parameters
that affect what the output is.
So how would you
tune application
to run the best it can,
given that the users can set
all of these different things?
It's a trick question.
You don't have to.
You're using Dataflow.
OK, so a bit more of context--
so machine learning
workflows, force parse data,
typically have three steps.
You preprocess data, you
train, and you serve the model.
And in this case, we are looking
only at the click-through rate
prediction.
But if you wanted to do
things like recommendation,
you would have a
different input types
that you would want to add,
things like the inventory,
or user information.
And you would have
to perform join,
which would make it
much more complicated
pipeline than the one that we
are looking in this example.
And for more data
details, you can see
many of the next ML sessions.
And actually, the
code of application
is a PythonSDK, Beam Python.
And it's available in GitHub.
OK, again, reflection
on a pipeline,
read, decode, analyze and
transform, encode and write.
So running this pipeline,
let's look how it looks like.
So we have a 10 gigabyte input.
It's a fraction of a data set.
And this is how
the worker profile
looks for this pipeline.
So on the x-axis, we have time.
This is run from a
week ago or something.
On the y-axis, we have
number of workers.
And as the pipeline
starts, our initial
estimated that it should have
around 40 workers for reading.
And then the blue
line actually shows
the workers, actual workers.
The green line is our
estimate and what we want,
what the system is
asking to happen.
So the blue line ramps up to 40.
And then it runs,
runs, runs, and figures
that I can use a little
bit more parallelism here.
So it jumps up, and
then once it gets
to a bigger stage, like
analyze transform thing,
it jumps up a lot.
And it goes from like around
50 workers to 107 or 108.
And then it finishes
and it's done.
So this job was around
21 minutes 20 seconds,
and it used 38 CPU hours
and 144 gigabytes of RAM
and five terabytes of PD hours.
Now the same input but with a
different threshold parameters
for the pipeline.
So this is
application parameter.
Like, I want you to produce
more detailed results.
So it makes it more
expensive to run it,
or more computational expense.
So this is how that
one looks like.
It looks similar, right?
But the differences are,
the y-axis now goes to 150
and above.
And again, we start with a
maybe slightly higher estimate.
We keep going.
There is, again, that bump
when we figure out there
might be some more
parallelism here.
Let me utilize it.
And then once we get
to the expensive stage,
we just ramp up high
and then add some more.
And we run it like 173 workers.
And the runtime is almost the
same, 22 minutes 17 seconds.
But you end up using
way more resources,
61 CPU hours, 230 gigabytes
of RAM, and 8 terabytes of PD.
My point here is not
that this was more
computationally intensive.
My point is that it was the same
common line as far as Dataflow
is concerned.
The only change
was in parameters.
And we were able to
keep all these workers
busy for the duration
of the pipeline.
They were utilized at 100% in
terms of what they are doing.
So now we want to look
at the larger scale.
The full input size
is one terabyte.
What does that do to the graph?
There are a few changes.
First, our y-axis goes to 1,000.
This is a system limit--
and I'm going to show it later--
and when we initially started,
we figured out between 500,
600 workers would be good.
So we again start
running the first part.
We had the bump, like we think
there is more parallelism here,
but then we were like,
no, we were good.
So we came back down.
And then we have this part,
which actually corresponds
to a group by key step.
What happens in a
group by key step
is you collect all the
data from incoming charts,
and then you have to
group them by key.
And this operation is
sort of two-step one.
And you cannot proceed the next
stage until you are fully done.
Because you need to be sure
that you saw all the keys.
So what happened here
is that the group by key
couldn't really fully keep
up with what was coming in,
so it had to finish.
Now, they do use dynamic
work rebalancing,
but there are always more
opportunities for improving,
and this is one of them.
So what happened here is,
while we were finishing
the tasks that
weren't paral further,
we shut down the other ones.
There was no reason for these
machines to sit there idle,
because they
couldn't do anything.
And then once that
step was done,
we shoot up in parallelism
and we were using
the system imposed maximum.
We do not go above 1,000
workers unless you tell us.
We think it's a reasonable
maximum to have by default.
OK, so this process, this
job, took one hour 30 minutes
and used quite a
bit of resources.
And in terms of scalability, the
input ratio size was 100 times,
the CPU ratio size
was 104 times.
In terms of gigabyte RAMs
used, it was 104 times as well.
And the PD usage was 52 times x.
And the wall time ratio was 4.2.
The ideal scalability in this
case would be one, right?
But Amdahl's law
is pretty strong.
So this part where
we had to shut down
and slowdown really does
affect the performance.
But we don't waste resources.
Now, let's look at the
performance of this application
over the last six months.
Again, it's important
application to the sister team.
And we are with them
monitoring what's happening.
So the red line shows the
runtime over a six months
period.
The initial drop there was
a bunch of data flow level
improvements that we did on the
Python SDK, or Beam Python SDK,
after [? GL ?] launch.
So we spent time improving the
connectors and these things,
and that had a very visible
impact on the runtime
of the performance.
Note that the application did
not change in this time period.
So these are all
the improvements
that are happening,
or all the changes
were happening from
system perspective,
from tool perspective.
And this here, we
enabled the autoscaling.
And that was another
drop in a duration time.
And then at this time someone
had the brilliant idea
that, hey, we are looking at
the resource usage and this.
What does it mean for the cost?
So we start tracking how
much the application costs
at that point.
And I think in that moment, we
were running at 62 minutes wall
time, and it cost around $225.
And end of January,
we were at 57 minutes,
so there were no major
reduction in the vault time,
but our price is
significantly lower.
And what this tells
you is that the system
became more efficient.
Maybe your vault time
that much, but you
are using less resources.
And it's the same application.
They're running it
continually, essentially.
And I think this is like
one of the core things
that I would like you
to come out with this,
is we really care about the
cost effective performance.
And we treat it as a first
class feature of the system.
And with that, we'll
switch the gears
and look at our Cloud
Dataproc product.
We will look at how
the system level
improvements affect the
performance in Cloud Dataproc.
So what is Cloud Dataproc?
Dataproc brings the widely used
Apache Hadoop and Apache Spark
ecosystems to GCP.
It is fully managed, it's
easy to use, it's fast,
and it's cost effective.
And I'll talk about all of them.
So how does the Cloud Dataproc
cluster lifecycle looks like?
Well, when you need to
you start one cluster.
You then use it.
And you'd run
Spark, Hadoop, Hive,
any of these Apache open
source ecosystem tools,
and then when you're
done you shut it down.
You delete the cluster.
So it doesn't use your time.
While you're using it, you
can still modify the cluster.
So you know, you start to
with a big cluster with like,
20 machines, whatever,
now you need 50.
And you can pretty
simply change that
to a bigger size or smaller
size, depending what you need.
So this is exciting.
I mean, if you think you bring
up your cluster, you use it,
you shut it down, there
is some like power to it
when you do it.
But like, often Spark and Hadoop
systems are slow to deploy
and they're costly and complex.
So start, use, and
delete sounds, you know,
wasteful if you're going
to spend a lot of time
starting the things.
But that's not the case
with the Dataproc, right?
Oh yeah, and we do
one-minute billing.
So starting a Cloud Dataproc
is as simple, literally,
as going to have a page,
clicking Create cluster,
optionally configuring
it, and doing start.
And within a 90 seconds
from the beginning,
you can have a machine
sped up, fully configured.
Whenever you need
to change it, you
go back to configuration page
and you change the parameters
that you want.
So the major goal of
Dataproc is to bring
the power of Google
Cloud Platform
to Spark and Hadoop users.
The team builds connectors
and integrations
with other Cloud products,
like BigQuery, Cloud Storage,
Cloud Bigtable, Cloud
Spanner, Compute Engine,
and allows you to read and
write from these seemingly.
One of the example
jobs that they have
is like PySpark job that
takes the data from GCS,
uses a PySpark, and then produce
the output in a BigQuery.
So how does it look
like under the hood?
So we have our clients on the
left hand side and the Google
Cloud Platform on the right.
And Dataproc exposes
the rest APIs
for managing the cluster,
for managing the jobs,
and other operations
that you may want to do.
So you can access
these APIs through UI,
or you can script
against them, like, you
can program against this API.
Next, Cloud Dataproc
has the clusters
that will build on top
of compute engines.
And there is this Dataproc
agent that manages--
it's sort of control plane--
and it manages your cluster,
makes sure that VMs are
up and things like that.
And this also, the
image that we have,
is built on top of Big Top.
So it comes with Spark, Hadoop,
Hive, and many other things
that are there.
When the cluster is
brought up, we also
bring up some persistent
disks and we install the HDFS
on them, or we make them
available through HDFS.
However, if you want to use
the start, use, stop cycle,
you cannot really keep the
input and outputs on the HDFS,
because it goes away
when you're done.
So what you do instead is you
put your inputs and outputs
on Cloud Storage, in BigQuery,
on one of these services that
are always up but do not come
down and up with your cluster.
So at some point on a
bright day last year,
in our regular performance
analysis things,
we noticed a problem.
And the problem was
that for big jobs,
accessing a big amount
of data on GCS, the read
and write were spending a lot
of time in SSL related code,
so much more that it wasn't
a bottlenecked on network,
but it was bottlenecked
on CPU operations.
Like, we're bottlenecked on CPU.
Remember I said that we
recommend GCS store users,
so this was surprising.
So we analyzed it and
determined the Java
based SSL implementation
is very CPU bound.
And once we identified
the problem,
we could come up
with a [? fifty ?]
solution momentarily that
would help the people who
are affected make it run
better, but we really
wanted to do it in
a systematic way
to make it available
to all of our users.
And that meant that we needed
a system level solution that
will be deployed to everyone
and will make everyone's
life better, not just the
few that were complaining
that things are slow.
So what's the solution?
The solution was to switch
implementation to BoringSSL.
And because it's BoringSSL,
it's boring name,
I had to have a
unicorn that sparkle.
So what it involved, well,
quite a bit of things.
But essentially, over
the next few weeks,
the old Dataproc customers
will have significantly
improved read and write
performance to GCS.
And essentially,
these are the results.
So we're looking at the
TestDFSIO benchmark.
x-axis is throughput.
The more the merrier, so you
want a higher throughput.
And light blue is
the old method,
and dark blue is the
BoringSSL method.
And essentially, we are
seeing 2 and 1/2 times faster
reads, and around
20% faster writes,
and there are no user changes.
It's just like the new system
configuration that runs.
And the different jobs will
see different benefits,
because if your job wasn't
bottlenecked on this,
this is not going to
significantly improve it,
because your end time depends
on more than just this.
But this is another example of
like, systematic improvement
that goes in a system,
and if you were watching
your application over
time, will make it cheaper
and more efficient to run.
So we'll have some
takeaways now.
So when trying to achieve
the performance and you
want to do that automatically
for data processing
applications, the tools have
to look at the different types
of factors.
We had application level
factors, environmental factors,
and system factors.
We try to systematically
address all three of them
across both of these products
and across those GCP.
Performance is
something we care about
and we look at all the time.
We have dedicated
people for that.
In our talk, we covered
the application aspects
and the environment
aspects and how
we deal with them
through Dataflow,
looking at the dynamic
work rebalancing,
autoscaling the graph
optimizations we do.
And on the system side, we'll
look at Dataproc and how
they improved one of the
core system libraries
by replacing it,
essentially, to increase
the performance
of read and writes
to GCS, which is a very common
pattern that our users use.
So data processing tools
help your application achieve
performance automatically.
We systematically
tackle different factors
that affect the performance.
And we provide real
time autotuning
in Cloud Dataflow and
system level improvements
in Cloud Dataproc.
And we make improvements to the
system and tools continually.
So we take the performance
available to you
out of the box, and then
no knobs are needed.
[MUSIC PLAYING]